blade explain what we're doing today
today we're not playing through a
console we're playing through a Samsung
television now we're gonna play one of
my favorite games power wash simulator
this is all about uh cleaning stuff you
van serial killers you game as well this
is probably how you like to relax it's
brushing up on your crime cleanup skills
uh the feds will never catch me blood
and fingerprints be gone look at that
gnome being such a dick look at his face
his whole attitude is like I'm better
than you [ __ ] you gnome do I knocked the
gnome down gnome is the only witness
sorry gnome this acid will take care of
you this is the gnome that told me to
kill kill kill I'm shooting water at an
electrical outlet
let's see if I die the way I should
we're going to start off in this cart
oh so which one is sick so Hugo the
little kid is sick am I did no you're
you're you're the girl you're the girl
I'm the girl can I say something yeah in
this scenario I envy the horse because
he doesn't know what the hell's going on
doesn't care and has a simple job to do
we're looking for a boy and a girl
pervert turkey what are you looking for
a boy and a girl for you a creep that
was an argument and men were slaughtered
oh my God younger brother witnessed it
oh that's horrible that's everyone's
excuse for why they want a boy and a
girl they committed some evil crime we
must take possession of them and put
them in this sack
are they wearing small shorts sorry uh
we may put these small shorts on before
we confiscate them
What's Happening Here who's he he was
the guy trying to treat him but Hugo's
having a seizure calm down your whole
circulatory system is visible calm down
don't hug him
chest is about to collapse try to sleep
try to sleep you go forget the fact that
your chest looks like a road map of
central Paris
don't worry about it you go with it Reds
yes remember oh you could see they were
everywhere they were giant waves of them
50 feet high
I wanted to stop too please make the
Game Stop it's an unrealistic number of
rats